desde el momento que ha tomado que han
llegado al poder en 2019
a muchas fueron las declaraciones de del
expresidente
antidemocráticas ha contribuido
muchísimo para el clima de tensión y
ahora vemos en Brasil a las protestas en
general son
típicas de los movimientos de izquierda
pero en este momento en Brasil tenemos
movimientos de extrema derecha y que
usan la violencia y lo que vimos el
pasado domingo fue una cosa terrible
entonces que después de este terribles
eventos que ven que vivimos por la tele
en que hubo una gran destrucción de los
tres poderes las tres casas del poder en
Brasil el expresidente ha apostado en
sus redes sociales creo que Facebook
específicamente
algo
reafirmando su duda con relación a los
resultados de las elecciones y
justificando la acción de los golpistas
Entonces qué después el borró esta
publicación pero
como recuperar este este
publicación y bueno y por ese motivo
creo que principalmente el ministro
alejandre de moral
demoraest de
superior tribunal
el supremo tribunal en Brasil
ha acogido la
el pedido de de la procuraduría general
de Brasil el fiscal general y bueno
bolsonar está incluido en las
investigaciones
Sí
también se ha pedido allá en Brasil o se
ha indicado que se pedirá la extradición
del exministro de Justicia Anderson
Torres si no regresa al país antes del
lunes Cuál ha sido también su hipotético
papel en los acontecimientos y Qué
representa su figura dentro del ámbito
bolsonarista
es un país es una federación Así que el
ministro de la justicia brasileño del
gobierno pasado
Alexandre Torres Este ha sido contratado
para ser el secretario de justicia en el
gobierno estatal distrital en verdad de
Brasil por el gobernador ahora ha estado
del Poder y podéis Rocha Entonces qué
tengo por el hecho de el responsable por
la aseguranza del Distrito en el periodo
de los atentados
estará ausente está fuera de Brasil en
este momento se configuró una situación
de omisión grande
que
por ese motivo ha sido aplastado Del
Poder
y ahora tiene que
contestar por lo que pasó que explica a
los poderes contenidos qué ha pasado y
por qué no ha hecho
las decisiones necesarias a la
protección de las tres casas del poder
en Brasil
Ah bueno
también está ignorando en Estados Unidos
y dice que va a venir pero ya está
diciendo ir diciendo Esto va a ser
baterías y todavía no ha hecho que va a
estar mañana pero no se está seguro de
esto entonces con
instituciones están muy tolerantes
esa decisión que que no vuelve hasta el
mes se va a repetir
Sí señora